so are you still a christian i still
believe in god but i
i don't think that i because you were a
guy that wouldn't jerk off
yeah i not until i was like 17 yeah
yeah really when i met you you're like
hang on i want to get
i want to get into this um so what would
you do when you would feel the urge
were you allowed to use your rub up
against a wall without using your hands
jesus no that sounds terrible like i
would get super creative
uh i would go to uh rock climbing gyms
[Laughter]
just you know just get stuck i'm stopped
i'm so stuck
in this crack uh just leave me for a
little bit
uh no i i don't know so
until older like i literally just didn't
know
i i had no sex education at the
christian school that i went to
they literally like we're going to skip
this section
oh wow abstinence that's the only word
that's the only thing you do yep we're
going to move on from that
yeah and it was one of those things
where i was like okay i just started
getting an ungodly amount of boners
where i was just like this is this is
crazy yeah like i was like dude if i
hugged a girl
in the hallway at high school
[Music]
just like immediately and i'm wearing
like basketball shorts and i'm the kid
who's like walking like with the books
and stuff
yeah yeah you know yeah just trying to
hide it and stuff like that so
then i started jerking off and then you
know loved it
and never feels good it
look like this oh god was there a bagel
on top they're bageling
there's literally yeah there's a bagel
there yeah
um did you ever go into pornography or
no
i did um only a few scenes i shot um
i i would look at porn but there's a lot
of guilt associated with that and i
actually so i haven't been looking at
porn during
the pandemic really which i've been
trying to avoid doing it because i feel
better about my relationship and
everything with my wife when i'm
not looking at that stuff i try not to
consume that stuff
because it makes it does make our sex
better for sure yeah if i'm avoiding
looking at
like graphic stuff online like it's just
it it is more special as cheesy
as that sounds but uh i do think like
i've i've done it both ways but when i'm
when i was on the road it's like you got
to take care of it on the road and i
would like
yeah you know go to town like you'd have
to yeah you have to yeah
do you get girls hitting on you on the
road now or no i don't think i put out
that vibe yeah you don't have a sexual i
know you're a sexual being
right right no i'm gonna throw that out
there you're a very sexual being
and i could see why women would be
attracted to you thank you so much bobby
but um you have mutante face
everyone mutants yeah it's like a mutant
you know you have a very like what what
is that disease that where
um the skin is inside out
harlequin bobby would send me photos all
the time
and say i just found your doppelganger
yeah
he would send me those photos all the
time
dude all the time you sent me the
graphic stuff i think there was one time
we were looking at
we were watching one of those shows and
like the kid had like pierre robin
syndrome
and you were like that's a baby jeremiah
yeah but you know um i apologize again
it's okay i'm changing as a person i
have to apologize because one time i i
did something as a comic that was
very embarrassing in front of you kalila
this and you i doubt you
i doubt you remember this i remember
everything you remember everything
we were at we are at a yard house after
one of the shows
at the improv and we were eating and
bobby was making asian jokes
and he was like saying jungle asian and
all this stuff
and i think i said like in asia